[موسيقى]
من قتم الوشقيق
كانت كان القرار قرار عشائري
اني اذكر بعض الاحداث
زوجه الاستاذ عزت الخاله ام احمد يعني
صديقه للوالده يعني احنا كعائله حاله
واحده تقريبا
صار اجتماع اعضاء قياده
وهنا
اعضاء القياده زعمهم عمي عزت
قال سياده الرئيس احنا كدوله
نسقط حقنا
في اتخاذ قرار الاعدام
لانه ذولا الرجال ازواج بناتك واولاد
لتسعى
حقنا نتنازل عنا في هاي الجزئيه يعني
لخاطرك اولا والخاطر
الاخرين هنا
احد الاقارب اللي كان في السلطه
رفع ايده قال له
نحن كعشيره ما نتنازل عنه
حقنا
في ان يتم قرار الاعدام
يعني
وهنا
اتخذ القرار بهذا الشكل
[موسيقى]
ولكن هناك كلام على انه رئيس هو الذي اصدر
الامر في النهايه وكان اصلا وتم يعني
باشراف من
عدي شقيق عدي صدام حسين صحيح هذا الكلام
ام لا
اذا اقول لك مو صحيح يعني راح ابعد شوي عن
الحق
ضيف الى هذا وذاك انه اللي صار
مو شيء حدث بين اثنين شوف
حتى انصف حالي
وحتى اكون صادقه لو انه الموضوع تم
بيناتنا الى ان اموت ما تطلع مني اي مفرده
لكن الموضوع اللي صار
عسكر يعني
مو جيش في المعنى يقصد عسكر موجودين
اصحاب القرار عندهم علم
فاتخذ القرار يعني يعني بعد اكيد
ما نقول بعد الرجوع الى الوالد هم اتخذوا
القرار بدون ان يرجعوا للوالد
[موسيقى]